we wanted to speak to the black
community specifically
because a lot of these concerns are
rolling around in our community like
misinformation
people with the wrong end of the stick
and we i wanted to do my bit we all
wanted to add a bit we've got to protect
ourselves as a community
because whenever i see the pictures of
the people that have passed
i'm always moved and shocked by the
amount of people
but also the amount of black and brown
people there and i think that we need to
address that we just think it will be a
tragedy if a disproportionate
amount of black people were to die of
covey due to a lack of take-up of the
vaccine this is our way out
this is this is the way out of the
pandemic we should all be doing it just
get it done
but there is this social media aspect
that's
some of the nonsense that's on social
media that can alter your dna
that you know bill gates has got
something to do with it that's inserting
a microchip
or something i mean but there's this
which is
palpable nonsense but people equally
have genuine concerns about it so how do
you address how do you address those
we know you have legitimate concerns and
worries we know that change needs to
happen in terms of the relationship
between
systemic racism and this feeling of
being hard done by by authorities
institutions
but we're asking people to trust the
facts from the experts
we know don't we that the vaccine has
been tested and is safe
for all ethnicities millions of people
have taken this jab
and we say that look if you've got
worries don't go online
or talk to your mate down the pub go to
a trusted
health professional or visit the nhs
website to find out more
trusted health professional nhs website
golden handshake jobs are good do that
so what have you heard people say when
they're asked about the vaccine
you know that made you go i can't i
don't want to hear this
it's got pork in it they're
experimenting you know it's all rubbish
really
it's it's just disinformation we should
work together to support
our loved ones and the people in that
community to help us all get through
this
yes we've got to address the health
inequalities in our system
we've got to rebuild this trust which
seems to have gone awol
but we have to remember that we're all
in this together and the people that
have signed this letter
you know these are not this is tandy
newton and dorian lawrence and chewie
talejafor and david ajay
and me and agent lester this is people
who
really care about our moms and dads our
gunners and granddads our brothers and
sisters
we want you to know that we've done it
i've had my job and i haven't exploded
so just trust the science
and get on with it because it individual
choice
has an impact on society i'm just seeing
a
imperial college survey says
you know that hesitancy around vaccines
could lead to
thousands of extra deaths we trusted the
science with mmr
and rubella and polio back in the day
i don't really see the difference we
need to keep trusting the signs and
trusting that
we're going to get through this and we
are going to get through this but there
has to be
trust and there has to be this sense of
all of us working together to get this
done and just finally what's your
message to those who are still
reluctant to have a vaccine please make
the decision
in an informed manner talk to somebody
you trust talk to a doctor go to the nhs
website
really listen and make an informed
decision
don't make it a misinformed decision and
we are all in this together whoever you
are wherever you're from
and we don't want this disproportionate
amount of black people
or anyone to die anymore let's all take
it and be safe